Ty Cobb I mean he was a solid B player
who became an A+ player because he was
smart he had some help
Ernie Harwell who was the man who got me
into sports when I was at Michigan law
brilliant brilliant voice wonderful
person and told me that they used to
have something an old Navin field where
Cobb played called Cobbs Lake and Cobb
would have him water that area every day
so his bunch just went and stayed there
and that was a hit Cobb could figure out
who could be intimidated when to run on
a batter for stolen base where to drop a
bunt when and he held his bat with his
hands apart and then as the pitch came
he put he'd move them up and down so to
direct the ball to where he wanted and
he hated Babe Ruth he hated because he
changed the game and then one day in
1925 because everybody was giving him
hell because Ruth was hitting homers he
hit three home runs in a game and said
there I can hit homers too and that was
the last time he tried he could play the
game here
pitchers some of them I always loved
Gaylord Perry who was known far and wide
for throwing a spit ball Perry will tell
you he didn't throw a spit ball that
often but he'd be licking his hands so
that they thought every pitch coming was
a spit ball because the batter has a
easier job than the pitcher the pitchers
got to keep him off-balance and throw
him what he doesn't expect so if you're
talking about intelligence that falls to
the pitcher or the catcher is calling
the signals because the games in their
hands
you know batting is a special science
those pitching but pitching requires
more of this
I remember once asking Barry Bonds Barry
how do you deal with this steroid crap
and I didn't say crap I was always very
subtle and he thought first thing he
said nothing beats eye to hand
coordination and you know what steroids
ain't gonna help you if he can't hit the
ball ain't gonna go further except into
the catcher's mitt
so batting I mean Ted Williams as great
a hitter as you was was less thinking
than his eyes his eyes he went to Korea
and second time around as a pilot in
fact his flight commanders name was John
Glenn who said he was the greatest pilot
he ever saw he comes back after a year
and a half out of baseball almost two
full seasons and he's taking batting
practice just to get his skills back to
the point where his hands were bloodied
from the number of times he had to swing
to get his rhythm and he went up to the
office of Tom Yawkey then the owner and
he said mr. yogi the plate is off no he
said you know it says yes we redid the
stadium we put everything back where it
belonged
we refurbished it he said it's off by
this much they measured for a year and a
half they've been playing with a plate
that was off this much who saw it Ted
Williams
I guess it's intelligence but it's also
eyesight
who's the greatest player I've ever seen
Joe DiMaggio Willie Mays second Roberto
Clemente third Clemente get Clemente is
lost in this because he didn't play in a
major market played in Pittsburgh he had
an arm that could throw out a runner in
the next County Willie Mays was
brilliant
DiMaggio only because I grew up with him
you know your first hero is always gonna
be your hero for life I don't care how
old you are when you fell in like with a
player that was your hero Joe Lewis was
my boxing hero
Sammy ball ba ugh that I still thinks
the greatest quarterback ever was my
first hero playing for the Redskins you
fell in like with someone
I'd say love but in today's society it's
got a different connotation everything's
got a different connotation today but I
tell any sports fan I asked him what was
your first hero and they'll tell me
Mickey Mantle for some Ted Williams for
some Joe Montana for some depending on
their age and their locale and I'll say
is he still your hero he says my
greatest hero because they that was when
they fell in love with sports
so that was their first hero and their
love for sports has grown but they
haven't lost that nostalgic reflection
and when I wrote the book the Baseball
Hall of Fame
I wrote a sort of insert for every
decade as for the greatest player ever
in that decade and it was Honus Wagner
who's terribly overlooked as the first
decade of the 20th century playing for
Pittsburgh he was the national East High
Cobb well when Ty Cobb and we do this in
the book we put all the plaques in in
their first five men voted into the Hall
of Fame where Ty Cobb and second was a
tie between Babe Ruth's and Honus Wagner
before Christie Matheson Walter Johnson
and they have the five of them as you'll
see in the book be
picture of Lee if you will first class
inducted into the Hall of Fame
and there's Honus Wagner who got as many
votes as Babe Ruth and today all anybody
knows about him is that he's the face on
the most valuable trading card linguist
what eight batting titles and stolen
base titles and etc etc and nobody
remembers except as a face on his
valuable card and that's unfortunate
we've lost some of that in the history
of baseball which has more history than
any sport all sports put together yes
we're into statistics now we've got on
base percentages no it's still history
and the stories are in the game
the statistics maybe the mortar of the
game the real I think if you will glory
of the game is encapsulated in stories
more than statistics say 367 you say Ty
Cobb that's the end of that conversation
you tell a story on Ty Cobb and now it
becomes more than a conversation became
becomes a mental note and really a
romantic one at some of them and some of
them about Cobb dreadful but still it
does more than only better 367 lifetime
okay that was exciting but I think the
greatest player ever was Babe Ruth not
just his home runs because every homerun
hit after him has his DNA in it but when
he was basically transferred from the
pitcher's mound to the outfield and the
reason for that was quite simply the Red
Sox had lost all their outfielders to
World War one and the abbess pitcher who
can hit he hits 11 home runs with that
which at the time with a dead ball led
the league in home runs they put a
mountain in the field and and in his
contract later with the Yankees he only
played the non Sun field right field in
Yankee Stadium left field in a lot of
places but
when he left the mountain he had 89 wins
at the age of 23 that's more wins than
any pitcher in the Hall of Fame at the
age of 23 except Beller and kid Nichols
and he went five more games with the
Yankees they just put him in the last
day of the season and he wins all five
appearances while still hitting home
runs while still hitting 342 this man
was a hell of a player and so I give him
greatest ever because of pitching and
hitting sure George Sisler pitched Cobb
even got into a game pitching he wanted
to pitch against Sisler who had been who
had been a pitcher before he became a so
had Bob lemon had become a fielder
before he became a pitcher sometimes you
shift positions Babe Ruth
greatest player ever no question in my
mind's eye